A CLAIM THAT TRUMP IS MAKING
ABOUT SAVING FLORIDA GOVERNOR
RON DeSANTIS' CAMPAIGN IN 2018
TALKING ABOUT SENDING IN FEDERAL
AGENTS AFTER THAT ELECTION WAS
CONDUCTED.
WE HAVE PAULA REED LIVE IN
WASHINGTON.
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT GOING ON IN
BETWEEN TRUMP GOING AFTER
DeSANTIS WHEN IT COMES TO MANY
POINTS BUT WHAT ABOUT THE CLAIM
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN 2018 AND
THE ROLE HE PLAYED AS PRESIDENT
SPECIFICALLY?
>> GOOD MORNING.
AS WE KNOW FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP HE CONTINUES TO ATTACK
DeSANTIS IN THE WAKE OF THE
GOP'S POOR MIDTERM PERFORMANCE
AND SUGGESTIONS THAT THE FLORIDA
GOVERNOR SHOULD BE THE ONE TO
LEAD THE PARTY HEADED INTO 2024.
IN A LENGTHY SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTLAST NIGHT TRUMP CLAIMED
THAT HE LEVERAGED FEDERAL
LAWSUIT TO STOP DeSANTIS FROM
LOSING HIS 2018 RACE FOR
GOVERNOR.
TRUMP WROTE WHEN VOTES WERE
BEING STOLEN IN BROWARD COUNTY
AND RON WAS GOING DOWN 10,000
VOTES A DAY, ALONG WITH NOW
SENATOR RICK SCOTT I SENT IN THE
FBI AND THE U.S. ATTORNEYS AND
THE BALLOT THEFT IMMEDIATELY
ENDED JUST PRIOR TO RUNNING OUT
OF VOTES NECESSARY TO WIN.
I STOPPED THE ELECTION FROM
BEING STOLEN.
THIS IS THE LATEST ITERATION OF
A CLAIM TRUMP MADE MANY TIMES
BEFORE ABOUT ELECTIONS BEING
STOLEN EVEN IN THE ABSENCE OF
ANY EVIDENCE.
I WANT TO PROVIDE CONTEXT FOR
THE 2018 RACE.
IN NOVEMBER 2018 GOVERNOR RICK
SCOTT, THE NOMINEE FOR SENATE.
ACCUSED TWO OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST COUNTIES OF FRAUD.
TRUMP TWEETED IN P, DON'T WORRY
FLORIDA I'M SENDING IN BETTER
LAWYERS TO EXPOSE THE FRAUD.
NOW SCOTT CALLED ON THE FLORIDA
DEPARTMENT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
INVESTIGATE.
THEY DID.
AND THAT 18-MONTH INVESTIGATION
FOUND NO EVIDENCE OF WIDESPREAD
FRAUD.
AS FOR TRUMP'S CLAIM THAT HE
SENT IN FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENTS?
WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO THE
CURRENT JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
FBI, AS WELL AS MULTIPLE
OFFICIALS AT THE TRUMP JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IN 2018, BUT SO FAR
THERE'S NOTHING WE HAVE SEEN TO
INDICATE THAT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP DID ATTEMPT TO LEVERAGE
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO HELP
REPUBLICANS IN 2018.
KAITLAN.
>> PAULA, THANKS FOR THAT FACT
CHECK.
JOINING ME IS FRANCIS ROONEY A
FORMER REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, CONGRESSMAN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
FIRST, WHAT DO YOU TAKE AS THE
MESSAGE FROM THE ELECTION SO
FAR?
IS THERE ONE RESOUNDING MESSAGE
FOR YOU?
>> YEAH, THE OVERRIDING MESSAGE
TO ME IS THAT TRUMP IS ONCE
AGAIN A BIG LOSER WHO CAUSED A
LOT OF TROUBLE FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
RECRUITED BAD CANDIDATES,
PERPETUATES THIS STOLEN ELECTION
MANTRA.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S GETTING
ANYBODY ANYWHERE.
>> WELL, THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HEARING MORE AND MORE FROM
REPUBLICANS, IN JUST THE LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS.
YOU GOT THE REPUBLICAN
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA
WHO IS NOW SAYING, A VERY
SIMILAR MESSAGE, IS THAT THE
MESSAGE FROM VOTERS IS IT'S TIME
TO MOVE AWAY FROM DONALD TRUMP.
AND ALSO THE SAME TAKEAWAY AS
RETIRING REPUBLICAN SENATOR PAT
TOOMEY.
AS YOU KNOW, DEMOCRAT JOHN
FETTERMAN JUST PICKED UP HIS
SEAT, NOW A DEMOCRATIC SEAT IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
LET'S PLAY WHAT PAT TOOMEY SAID.
>> I THINK MY PARTY NEEDS TO
FACE THE FACE THE FACT THAT IF
FEALTY TO DONALD TRUMP IS THE
PRIMARY CRITERIA FOR SELECTING
CANDIDATES, WE'RE PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO DO REALLY WELL.
>> YOU JUST SAID THAT AS WELL.
AND YOU HAVE BEEN SAYING THAT
FOR SOME TIME, I WILL NOTE,
CONGRESSMAN.
WELL, WHAT IMPACT DO YOU THINK
THIS MIDTERM HAS THEN, ON THE
MOVEMENT AWAY FROM TRUMP, IF
THAT MOVEMENT IS REAL?
>> WELL, WE SAW TIM GRIFFITH
COME OUT A COUPLE DAYS AGO, ONE
OF THE LARGEST REPUBLICAN
DONORS, I'VE WORKED WITH HIM
BEFORE, HE SAID IT'S TIME TO
MOVE ON FROM TRUMP.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE A LOT
MORE PEOPLE TAKE THAT KIND OF
POSITION.
WHAT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
INTERESTING HOW MANY OF THESE
PS
PSYCHOFAN CANDIDATES CONTINUE TO
GO TO TRUMP.
>> DO YOU THINK IT DIMINISHES --
THAT'S THE QUESTION, DO YOU
THINK IT DIMINISHES?
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING IN YOUR
CRYSTAL BALL WITH THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK THIS ELECTION
SHOWS THAT THIS MAGA GROUP IS A
VERY DEDICATED GROUP, BUT IT'S
NOT A MAJORITY.
AND IT TAKES MODERATE
REPUBLICANS, JUST AS IT TAKES
MODERATE DEMOCRATS TO WIN AND
THAT WAS GEORGE BUSH'S AND
RONALD REAGAN'S POINTS, AND THEY
ALL LOST BECAUSE OF BEHAVIOR.
WHAT SENATOR SPECTER SAID IS
ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
>> SENATOR TOOMEY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE IN THE ATTACKS
BY DONALD TRUMP OVER RON
DeSANTIS JUST OVER THE PAST 24
HOURS NOW?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT ACTUALLY
HELPS ROCK.
ANYBODY THAT KNOWS DONALD TRUMP,
ANYBODY THAT'S READ BILL BARR'S
BOOK FOR TALKED TO THE OTHER
CHIEFS OF STAFF OR OTHER PEOPLE
WHO HAVE HEARD HIS RANTS AND
RAVINGS AND PROFANITIES AND
THINGS IN THE WHITE HOUSE CAN
CONTEST TO THE FACT THAT HIS
BEHAVIORS ARE ALWAYS BRUTISH AND
IMMATURE.
I THINK THAT RON IS A STATESMAN
ABOUT IT.
AND THE MORE HE STAYS THAT WAY
THE BETTER HE'S GOING TO LOOK.
>> SOMEWHAT OF A BLUEPRINT FOR
OTHER REPUBLICANS.
FINALLY, I DO WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT KEVIN McCARTHY.
AND THE CHALLENGE AND STRUGGLE
THAT HE'S UP AGAINST RIGHT NOW.
HE HAS MEMBERS OF PRO-TRUMP
FREEDOM CAUCUS ARE NOW PLAYING
HARD BALL FOR THEIR SUPPORT FOR
HIM AS SPEAKER.
BEYOND THAT, CONGRESSMAN,
CONSIDERING HOW SLIM THE
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE MIGHT BE,
THAT STRUGGLE IS GOING TO EXTEND
RIGHT INTO LEGISLATING.
I MEAN, HOW TOUGH OF A ROAD DO
YOU THINK McCARTHY AND A SLIM
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY HAVE?
>> I THINK KEVIN WILL BE HARD TO
BEAT.
NOW, WHEN YOU GET INTO
LEGISLATING, IT'S GOING TO BE
HARD TO KEEP THE CORRAL FULL OF
MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS BECAUSE
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO GO THEIR
WAYS ON CERTAIN ISSUES THAT ARE
HOT BUTTONS TO THEM.
HE DID A GOOD JOB, THE LAST TWO
YEARS I WAS IN CONGRESS, ON
WORKING ON SOME OF THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS MEMBERS.
HE'S VERY CAREFUL.
I KNOW HE PUT JIM JORDAN WHEN I
WAS ON THE STEERING COMMITTEE IN
CHARGE OF THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS COMMITTEE WHICH IS
SOMETHING HE WANTED.
SO HE'S GOT A FEW ALLIES IN THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS NOW.
>> I WAS JUST THINKING, YOU MISS
IT?
NOW YOU THAT SEE WHAT THE
MAKE-UP MAY LOOK?
DO YOU MISS YOUR TIME AT
CONGRESS?
>> OH, NO, THE REASON I RAN --
YOU DON'T BECOME A NEW CAREER, A
POLITICIAN AT 67 YEARS OLD.
I RAN TO GET THAT MONEY TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT IN
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA.
AND WE'D GONE SO LONG WITHOUT
GETTING ANY APPROPRIATIONS TO
SAFER THE EVERGLADES AND FIX OUR
BEACHES AND REED NOURISH OUR
ESTUARIES, ONCE I ACCOMPLISHED.
I FIGURED IT WAS SOMTIME TO MOV
ON.
>> IT'S GOO TO HAVE YOU ON,